someone was messing with a loaded gun
we're trying to figure out who did it
and what happened driving throughout the
video Calise lost his freaking mind Sam
there's a serious issue drop everything
and call me so me Sam Dean Matt
Christian and Jake just got back from a
10-day trip in San Antonio Texas we were
shooting two short films you guys'll be
able to check those out really soon we
were always playing Smash Bros you know
it is we play smash was every night and
you know we come up with a pretty cool
game type and we're very excited to
share it with the world and it is called
what we call team trees kid you not we
were up for probably on average like two
hours a night this is it's a deep game
there's so much you can do short friends
what's that line down the middle of TV
yeah I don't know what that is not good
at all that is a problem that is
actually broken there was like a red
look at this line there's like that's
broken someone that's for the game
that's not part of the game dude it was
in the new software update not freaking
out right now
I think you guys have already been
through this yeah yeah there's there's
one of you who have caught it maybe
listen guys we're not telling you
anything
what what's going on last week knows
what happens and I know they do Ren
didn't come to Texas Nico didn't go to
Texas Wes and cliff didn't come to Texas
Griffon didn't come to Texas that's only
something went like some point it's a
Nerf dart it's a Nerf dart you shot the
TV that same that is that the same size
clearly the same size look at the
there's clear cracks we're not an earth
dirt it can't be that's written that
replicate the problem what if we damage
the TV more maybe we can do that thanks
I think that's the best way to do let's
try it
oh no no there's no crack no crack it
was a hundred percent hundred percent in
airsoft BB here
you have to separate the interrogate the
entire guys why is why I'm filming this
okay never wants to clear out everyone
it's the clear out hell it has to be me
yeah and red and in a five gallon water
bottles gotta get the junkie Brandon
he's gotta quit red tell me what
happened I don't know nothin don't make
me use this rent it was a cloudy and
stormy day we were just trying to play a
quick game of Smash Bros and then we
went home at the end of the days with
the damage TV let me see if your story
stacks up he's so at some point between
I'm pretty like playing some Smash
Brothers - see you guys later there was
a broken TV in there somewhere in that
gap what day was it last week when last
week it was one of the hours we were
gone for every hour last week
wait but who was still at the studio Wes
Wren Griffin Nico cliff cliff cliff as
well let's get cliff rent
I love beyond right now I hear it's like
Sicario back there let me know if you
need anything
actually I represent cliff cliff for
four years it's true but ever since you
moved out I now do all my dealings
through Wes yes I think we need to
review the footage footage was there's
footage you the footage I'm gonna check
the damn tapes I'm gonna talk with
Griffin because I think he knows
something okay Wesley Wesley
incorporated how many people do you
represent hi my name is Wes for Wesley
Wesley incorporated and I help you cover
up crimes that you may or may have not
committed
I've built a wide network of clients by
building my website with Squarespace
which also happens to be today's sponsor
Squarespace is the perfect tool for a
person like you or a lawyer like me to
build their client base Squarespace
allows for simultaneous posting that
means when you post to your website
it'll automatically format for Facebook
Twitter or tumblr now guys I have a
pretty popular podcast it's called the
Cali hammer
I use it to interview people that may or
may not have committed heinous crimes
with Squarespace
I can embed my SiC audio podcast using
audio blocks with Squarespace traffic
overview I see how visitors and page
these trend over time with multiple
contributors you can select different
people to help manage your site and give
different positions depending on what
you need I want you to go to Squarespace
comms slash corridor crew so you can get
10% off your first purchase and if you
guys have any what are you are you
pretending to be a lawyer no I'm just
telling them that here at Wesley Wesley
incorporated we're here to represent you
on crimes that you may or may have not
committed that's that's a felony
we are Wesley Wesley incorporated a lot
of people don't know that Jags
Wesley I can explain everything I like
it Clint's lost his freaking mind
the gentlemen are going a little too far
for my taste
wait just locked ourselves in here
well we're locked in the room I
accidentally locked ourselves in the
room I know this is like a fun like a
video idea but like I really need this
job guys drop the video we're just
looking for um these hey hey you're not
saying anything right no do not what do
you really do in a police case when it's
obvious that people know something that
when you pull the samurai sword I think
we need to talk to Nico because all the
leads have been pointing back to Nico
Griffin said he needs to keep his job
I really do Nico's a nice man see what
we can do
where were you on Thursday I represent
Nico as well okay
what's the Wesley incorporated who do
you represent everyone that wasn't in
Texas Wesley Wesley incorporated any
update on the files I haven't found any
files just happens to be a security cam
pointed right at the TV oh yeah
Christian Christian Christian I'm Jim
can you pull that do I have them from my
phone at least is 3:25 p.m. on November
8th neat sayfudine oh no no no everyone
in Texas let's check the files
do we see a clear line down the center
of the TV on Friday the day des training
came out here
we had clear evidence of a line down the
center of the TV on Friday November 8th
the day destron came out well that means
it happened on Friday or before yeah I
know how we can be heard we got a hack
into the mainframe one answer Sam answer
Sam there's a serious issue I need you
to call me back as soon as possible drop
everything and call me see you look at
him look at them all playing trees over
there with a broken TV it's him he's
calling yo dude okay look we're trying
to figure something out we turn on the
TV to play trees hero there's a massive
crack down the center of the TV we're
trying to figure out who did it and what
happened and it's come down to this I
don't have access to nest cam but we're
trying to figure out who did it
okay have a good one
goodness I would love for you to
continue all your hard work
yeah but I think it's possible until you
check the nest cam
or at least give me your phone which has
access to tell me what time you want to
look at all of Thursday I want to find
out it gonna happen - I think if any
shenanigans are gonna go down it's gonna
be after lunch Shannon gets happened
after lunch the line is there and
Thursday the line was there Wednesday
Wednesday let's see that TV line is the
lines there wait this is Tuesday no
Tuesday now still they're there until
they're zoom in is it okay
it happened on Tuesday I'm not seeing
any incriminating actions
who knows - no it was Tuesday Mike was
here I can call Mike we should call Mike
DJ well call Mike diva
yeah Mike do you have three minutes yeah
you were here at the studio on Tuesday
right yeah on Tuesday a BB flew into the
TV Oh what yes oh my god forgot about
you dude hi do you remember like what he
was wearing
or anything about him was he tall and
lanky
[Music]
and I helped you cover up cries of you
may or may have not committed baby penis
court yes
you didn't do it we know you didn't do
it look up new he's leaving with a
backup for you
it doesn't have to end this way and do a
line buddy end of a line with the BB gun
you thought wasn't loaded
it was West what he needs to complete
you're a good man West you can't go home
with this on your chest like this West's
friend all I have to say is run for West
[Music]
hey buddy coming out his tone out twice
don't let your worst day to find you
show us how it happened in the median I
just finished playing smash and I lost
and I watched I watch the guys continue
to match I picked up a piece of
equipment I took it and I took I took
the trigger and I pulled it Nico had
turned back it was like whoa I think I
said did that shoot something that was
it and it was cool everything was chill
and the next day I came in on my one
wheel happy
please just come here happy I looked the
Nico and I looked at Ren and they said
hey Wes can't guys remember that BB
as I can yeah man I was stupid they both
pointed toe
[Music]
everybody makes mistakes honesty and
truth and I try to protect everyone I
met you were protecting yourself for the
most part but it's fine website we
forgive you
there's a lot of truths that come and
clean like you did Wes I'm proud what we
call team trees but basically you're
just villager you'd only use your tree
move and you can pocket trees also a
very important thing to know there is
medicine and poison falling from the sky
so you might randomly just get huge and
be able to plant a giant tree or you can
be shrunk down to a little pea-sized
person like this and plant a little
broccoli tree